somebody jumped behind a bar and started
serving everybody drinks to keep things
moving I'm wondering if our next guest
can recall who that person was do you
remember who that was Jim Kelly that
person no hybridizes I think open you
know what guys I I was so used to that
grown up when I trace a drone up you
know later on in life when I was only
after surgery I have five brothers and
you never served a great question up for
them so as a little brother the younger
brother I had Martin go out so I had fun
doing it but you know what
when I see all my friends did frustrated
and your loved it your dreads yeah we
had one 15 minutes I have to come to the
rescue and I'm just out on my days claim
in our basement when I had parties after
the game I always been behind the bar
helping out the bartender's we had to
make sure proof and pastor Cantwell and
because all those guys had their curse
on time right and then and then and then
Jim Kelly who was the one who told the
Pro Football Hall of Fame folks to to
get a specific spot for all the Hall of
Famers during the ceremony to perhaps
get a fresh one get a cold one to get
through a very warm summer day and
evening of speeches who was that they
wound up calling that little locker room
area after me telling you know when my
group was the first time ever from the
stadium Wilder's that little locker room
area and anybody came back there they
always had beer but in order to
disappear you had to sign the equipment
wall and some guys didn't want to do it
I said woke her up inside their wall for
them you don't get a beer or a hotdog
and so I started making sure that I
would do that and they did but
unfortunately now the stage is on the
complete opposite side of
that little locker room bar area was and
but still they find a way for the boys
have a cold one when it's like 95
degrees and Harper sent you minute well
you are a people person Jim Kelly that
is for damn sure how how are you doing
how are you feeling I'm doing all right
I just hope the listeners out there can
understand me I still have no upper job
and I I'm kidding for presents resort I
went in about three weeks early because
I was having some major pain in my mouth
and I just wanted to make sure that the
sensor did not come back and thank god
it did not I just have some issues with
saying that we were trying to figure out
what it is and but overall I think good
noise that I'm still wrong I mean I know
that he's just planning for me to be
able to go out there continue to don't
cross the country speaking to a bunch of
different groups and uh but right now
I'm blessed to be able to talk to Rick's
I always enjoy being always you you're
one of my favorites and I you're gonna
buzz pools that come meet right back at
you Jim Kelly right back at you your
speech was awesome your SP speech was
Chris great Jim it really really was I
mean I probably one of the nurse times I
had because here I had my wife trying
tell me what to say I had no friends and
don't forget me in I mean get more
friends messin with me and then I'm
saying you only got three or four
minutes but to be honest we take your
time whenever you say you saying and all
of a sudden I but I'm not much daughter
to walking up on stage with me and and
they want your early on you wanted me to
have a secret and I go guys I I don't do
well dreaming speeches I go I love to
speak from the heart and I was trying to
tell it like it is and give me a couple
footnotes and I'll go from there but I'm
not into reading speeches I mean to just
speak them for my my heart whatever
comes out comes out call a Famer Jim
Kelly hear what it mean you have Elway
and Marino bring you up onstage Jim that
was awesome I mean we go way back and as
I said during my um my speech has done
all the good times that we had each
other's golf tournaments
I'm never places should be honest with
you that was back in the day when we all
had our own golfers and Bernie Kosar
Boomer Esiason Jim Everett one Mooney
Marino Elway and we would go to each
others and it was so much fun and that's
really where we got to know because
there's a court being across the baby
three the three of us then all three of
us in Hall of Fame and we battled on a
football field but once we left a
football field we're best friends and we
still are and because good to see those
guys do well and your families are doing
well so I'm all good and it was it was
an honor and humbling humbling
experience it was procedures gonna be
knowing guys like Stewart shop you know
receivers in the past and what can we be
as meant to just this country and how he
has been able to make a difference and I
could coach that hope that I can scratch
the surface on what Jimmy B is done and
continued as far others who never ever
give up that we all go through tough on
your life and gratitude that you have
and keeping that out to positive and if
your people out there that you see
you're not doing well man what a smile
will do for them what a hug what how are
you doing how that changes their lives
and I learn personal experiences of
course I've also learned by seeing
somebody an order of an elderly
gentleman or lady that just looks like
that you need somebody to say hi to talk
to and I'm willing to do that right now
it's real hard because I really don't
have my future to be able to have to
understand and take a lot of pictures
but hopefully will become within the
next month month and a half so if you
plug along with joy myself and how much
time luck them yeah that's so are you
gonna be able to make it to Canton next
week you're gonna be there I'm not
already I have an appearance in
Cleveland I have to go there and it
always depends how I feel the worst part
about it rich is when I go there out to
do so much talking and for me that kills
me and I can't really take pictures
because I says
smile I would love to be there but I
don't want to go there coming up in the
field because that's probably the worst
thing for me to do is go somewhere where
I have to do a lot of talking so I don't
know yet it is helping the earth 5050
and I won't be so a lot of some magician
yeah okay well then I don't want to keep
you talking too long here but I just
love talking to you
you know I well I'm in back as young I
was having you know go an hour with your
bridge work that just does not happen
anymore and I've been yelled at by my
wife too many times I need to slow down
and sometimes you can say no to pulling
I'm just very hard for me to do that but
I won personally I could not say no to
now we're here if they don't for a few
minutes and tell ya that I know so many
people that listen to you and just logs
ah here your your thoughts about losses
going on and I'm not used to so then the
last thing I love you for saying that
but it really it's not about me I just
wanted to because you're so
inspirational every time we have you on
as a guest
it's just you know our twitter feed and
our and our response is just light up
certainly based on who you are and what
you stand for so then the last thing I
will just ask you to do is for those out
there who are perhaps wondering about
their futures their health their
families what what advice do you give
them Jim Kelly I think anything that
I've learned throughout the whole
experiences always surround yourself
with positive people people with good
attitudes or so many people out there
that knows our walk into a room and
you're crying or they have time on their
face and one of the things in my family
and my friends always did no matter how
bad I was when he walks into my room
they've walked in with a smaller page
and they wanted to make me feel better
by their presence in and as I said my
speakers where it doesn't have to be
able to Brian James it doesn't have to
be a Jim Kelly you're gone that way or
you know you're Rogers somebody like
that to be able to make a difference
there's so many people out there yeah I
mean I said in my speech it doesn't
matter your mother your father your
grandparents and your order discipline
it's not having a good day and they
don't have to have a chance because it's
been off your
go over toss them Kay hello would you
like spent 20 minutes talking people
shine 2 minutes a dead finish you're
spending with them to make their day so
much better and make them think about
continuing to put God and to get better
into never ever give up there's too many
people I've met that dude probably
deserves or you know can you send a note
and you know it's not a picture tell my
mother and my father not to ever give
out food right now they don't want to
live anymore there's so many people out
there to give up too easy so this
everybody out there be a difference
maker in somebody else's life love you
Jim Kelly I do hope to see you next week
and if not then then I know that I'll be
seeing you shortly
god bless and I will talk to you down
the road buddy you got it that's none
other than Jim Kelly Hall of Famer at
Jim Kelly 1212 the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience